you got the
feeling I know
there you got a
feeling I
[Musica]
know
a
[Musica]
W
h
[Musica]
sono cose cheo si capiscono
molto Allora Ecco perché vi ho voluto
far vedere questo video perché è quello
per cui mi batte ogni giorno è
l'obiettivo di spiegare alla politica
alle istituzioni all'opinione pubblica
quanto il settore dello spettacolo sia
strategico e non uso una parola
Eccessiva per il nostro paese però Sì
l'hanno detto prima consentitemi di
dirlo sono qui e lo devo necessariamente
ricordare con gioia Sono nato qui sono
cresciuto qui sono andato via Cavalier
Callipo sono andato via perché in fondo
tanti di noi sarebbero rimasti se questa
realtà se questa città ci avesse offerto
maggiori opportunità io la La ringrazio
perché la sua commozione dimostra quanto
sia stato difficile restare e la
ringrazio anche a nome di coloro che
sono andati andati via perché una è
veramente forte immaginare di poter
restare e di poter offrire il proprio
contributo qui però oggi torno con
orgoglio torno con l'orgoglio di Chi ha
costruito un bagaglio E di chi vuole
raccontare un bagaglio che è stato
alimentato da due passioni fondamentali
la politica e lo
spettacolo perché vedete la politica non
è sterile contrapposizioni non è il
vociare che sentiamo nei Talk Show Non
può essere vero esercizio del potere Ma
la politica
anche soprattutto nella migliore
accessione del termine rappresentanza di
interessi collettivi Allora io a un
certo punto ho deciso di mettere insieme
queste due passioni di fare per mestiere
colui che rappresentava gli interessi
dello spettacolo ed allora avete visto
Ci sono delle parole chiave qui perché
lo spettacolo non è solo ciò che vedete
sul palco è un po' quello che state
vivendo anche in queste ore qui con noi
ma lo spettacolo è molto di più e la
prima parola chiave è proprio
valorizzazione cosa intendo dire con
valorizzazione Avete visto proprio nel
video dei luoghi di significativo valore
artistico culturale storico che trovano
attraverso perform performance
attraverso dei momenti di spettacolo
un'ulteriore valorizzazione un'ulteriore
occasione di essere visti e di essere
frequentati e diventano anch'essi un
elemento fondamentale dello spettacolo
ma qualsiasi territorio trova
valorizzazione attraverso delle
performance e quindi passo alla seconda
parola è promozione e promozione perché
un territorio attraverso le attività di
spettacolo promuove se stesso promuove
il proprio Brand promuove la propria
immagine rafforza la propria reputazione
noi facciamo spesso un esempio un
esempio di Berchidda è un piccolo paese
in Sardegna di 2500 abitanti che ha
avuto la sola fortuna di avere tra i
suoi concittadini Paolo Fresu il grande
jazzista che ha scelto di impiantare
nella sua città natale il Fest il suo
festival Ebbene berid da oggi è una
delle capitali internazionali del
gzz la terza parola chiave è
investimento prima sentivo parlare spesa
improduttiva
investimento è chiaro che queste sono
attività come prevede la nostra
Costituzione che devono essere sostenute
dallo stato dagli enti locali dalle
regioni perché non sono attività che
riescono a vivere sul
mercato però vi o non è un ritorno
dell'utilizzo di questi fondi
pubblici attraverso attraverso queste
attività vedete lazia l'associazione
generale dello spettacolo per cui lavoro
ha fatto uno studio ogni euro investito
in un evento culturale Porta su quel
territorio €250
più del doppio di quanto viene investito
vogliamo ancora parlare di spesa
improduttiva ed è proprio facendo
riferimento a questo investimento voglio
dirvi una cosa siamo qui nel mezzog
giorno d'Italia Purtroppo lo Stato
investe oggi tantissime delle sue
risorse in questo settore nel centro
nord e pochissimo nel sud questo
necessita di un equilibrio territoriale
ma necessita anche di una sveglia da
parte nostra la proposta culturale che
noi offriamo al paese probabilmente
ancora non è così forte da poter avere
un sostegno vero da parte dello stato e
il lavoro e lavoro perché la pandemia
non vi tegio con la pandemia però ha
acceso un grande riflettore un
riflettore verso nei confronti dei
Lavoratori dello spettacolo sapete
proprio qualche giorno fa l'ins ha
ricordato quanto gli iscritti al fondo D
pensioni dello spettacolo siano 350.000
in questo paese
oltre a loro ci sono tanti lavoratori
dell'indotto degli eventi cioè
immaginate macchinisti immaginate
tecnici immaginate tutti coloro che non
afferiscono a quel fondo ma che lavorano
grazie a queste attività Ebbene
nonostante la pandemia questo numero ne
lavoratori è cresciuto del 10% nel dal
2021 al
2022 tutto ciò per dire che esistono dei
Lavoratori delle famiglie che su queste
attività costruiscono redditi
costruiscono il loro futuro il mondo
dello spettacolo non è assolutamente
qualcosa di voluttuario ma è anche un
lavoro ed è benessere è benessere e non
Lo sostengo io lo sostiene
l'organizzazione Mondiale della sanità
professore l'organizzazione Mondiale
della sanità nel 2019 in una sua
pubblicazione ha acclarato come la
partecipazione ad attività culturali e
l'espressione creativa influiscono nel
miglioramento della salute e del
Benessere delle persone e della comunità
ed è benessere anche per perché è
emozione profonda come dice l'ultima
slide quando voi andate a vedere un
concerto Andate a vedere uno spettacolo
teatrale un bel film in una sala
cinematografica condividendolo con altri
vedete quello è un momento unico un
momento in cui si vive una dimensione
completamente differente rispetto a
quella che è la nostra quotidianità e lo
si fa condividendo insieme ad altre
persone questa esperienza bene non è la
stessa cosa Quando ciò accade nella nel
Nella nostra casa magari attraverso la
visione di un bel film in una
piattaforma attraverso anche dei scheri
dei belli schermi televisivi che oggi
sono concessi nelle nostre nelle nostre
case Ebbene è molto di più è molto di
più è l'ultima slide con la quale
intendo dirvi che tutto questo tutto
quello che voi Vedete vedete su un palco
è un momento che mette insieme
tradizione ed innovazione è un momento
in cui si incontra anche il grande
linguaggio nuovo i nuovi le nuove le
nuove occasioni appunto di linguaggio i
social media con un grande classi è un
momento in cui molto probabilmente ciò
che vedete rappresenta molto di più di
quello che probabilmente oggi le nostre
istituzioni si rendono conto e
valorizzano vedete potrei parlarvi
ancora per ore di queste nostre
possibilità di queste nostre esigenze
delle esigenze di un settore e tutto di
quello che può comportare a questo paese
però credo che riuscirei solo in una
cosa Nel
riconversioni voi dell'importanza di
questo settore per questo paese
[Applauso]
[Musica]
Grazie